من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه لواء فايز الدويري
بريغوجينيوس على انه ليس انقلابا عسكريا
بل تصحيح السلطات في مسقط التهمه بالتمرد
المسلح بناء على تطورات الاخيره في اي
خانه يمكن توصيف ما يقوم به
يعني هو تصرف غير من وجهه نظر القانون
الروسي او اي قانون هو يعتبر تمرد مسلح
واقرب الى تمرد مسلح لانه خرج عن دائره
الالتزام بالقوانين الناظمه للحياه العامه
من يمثل البعد العسكري في اي دوله هي
القوات المسلحه والاجهزه الامنيه الان
باجنر هي الشركه خاصه علما ان الدستور
الروسي لا يسمح بانشاء تلك
المنظمات ولكن هي خدمه الدوله الروسيه
خدمت الكرملين خدمه السياسه الخارجيه في
افريقيا في الشرق الاوسط وثم احتاجت لتحت
الضروره لان تشارك في القتال انجزت معجزه
الجيش الروسي عن انجازه هذا ولد نوع من
الاطماع الشخصيه لجا بريغوجين وبالتالي
بدا يطمح الى ان له دور في مستقبل الحياه
السياسيه الروسيه احدها الاقصى ان يكون
خليفه بوتين حدها الادنى ان يكون رئيسا
للمؤسسه العسكريه الرسميه او على الاقل ان
يكون له جيش موازي للجيش الروسي كما هو في
الحرس الثوري الايراني وبالتالي هذا ادى
الى تفاقم الازمه الان ان يتحرك 25 الف
جندي مقاتل باسلحتهم من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والغابات في اوكرانيا الى
روستوف ويقوم كما قال باسقاط طائره عموديه
يحاول محاصره القياده العسكريه
يطالب باعدام وزير الدفاع اذا هذا هو في
المنظور العسكري هو تمرد عسكري لكن هو
ينته تهمه الانقلاب لماذا لان هناك خط
فاصل ما بين التمرد وما بين الانق عندما
نتحدث عن انقلاب نتحدث عن تغيير البنيه
السياسيه نتحدث عن تغيير
هيكله اداره الدوله لو كان انقلابا عسكريا
يعني الاطاحه بالكرملين بينما الان كتمرد
عسكري هو يصفه بانه توجه لتصحيح مسار ليس
تمرد هو يعتبر ان هناك اشخاص فانشروا في
اداره المؤسسه العسكريه فشلوا في تحقيق
انجازات
خدعوا الرئيس بوتين بمسببات الحرب فيجب ان
يتم محاسبتهم وتصحيح المسار العسكري لكن
كل كل شخص يفسر الاجراءات على الارض كما
هو يراها هو يقول عنه تصحيح المسار نحن
نقول من بعد عسكري لا هو خروج على المالوف
وخروج على القانون ويعتبر بدايه التمرد
والتمرد
عن مصدر الامير روسيه مقاتله فاجنر
السيطروا على جميع المنشات العسكريه في
جنوب موسكو وهذه الصور التي نتابعها هي
لمقر قوات
بطرسبورغ مراسله قد تحدث عن توجه
عناصر امنيه الى محيط المركز دون حديث عن
اقتحامات حتى الان ولكن ربما تمهيد
الاقتحام المركز يعني سيد الدويري عندما
يقول
بريكوجين ان الخلاف حتى الان مع وزير
الدفاع وقائد القوات المسلحه واذا لم يتم
تسليمه ما لهيهدد بتوجه نحو موسكو هل يعني
هذا هل يفهم منه ان التمرد يمكن ان يتجاوز
وزير الدفاع وهيئه قائد هيئه الاركان
يعني اذا جاز الوصف اقول ما يجري في روسيا
الان هو كره ثلج تتحرك تكبر مع الحركه
اتجاهات الحركه غير معروفه هكذا اوصف
الامر حقيقه الاحداث تتضخم مع مرور الوقت
اتجاهات الاحداث غير واضحه الكل ينتظر
خطاب سيد الكرمنيل الرئيس بوتين الان
الحديث عند انسان بطرسبرج عن مقر القياده
هل بريجوجل في مقر القياده ام يقود قواته
في ريستوف هو يقود قواته فيروس لا يعني
السيطره لا اقلل من السيطره على مقر باجنر
في سان بطرسبورغ ولكن الحدث الاكبر في
رستق وليس في سان بطرسبورغ كما قال هو
الان
سيتحرك الى موسكو لكن كان هناك قبل ساعه
تقريبا
المسؤول في منطقه موسكو امر باتخاذ
اجراءات ووضع حواج ز وبدات الحواجز على
مسافه 420 كيلو متر جنوب موسكو اذا هناك
تخوف وبالتالي بدات الامور لا اقول تخرج
عن السيطره ولكن كما قلت لك الامور
الاحداث تكبر مع المرور الوقت والاتجاهات
غير معروفه من سيثبت الاوركسترا الكليه
الرئيس بوتين ماذا سيقول هل يضع الخطوط
الحمراء
وطباخ بوتينر كيف سيعالج علينا ان ننتظر
خطاب الرئيس بوت